hey what's up i'm brenda i'm a tasting
producer and today we're going to be
making my favorite hispanic recipes
tortilla espanola is a dish that it
originates in spain they will eat it
gatherings mostly during the summer they
can eat it cold and hot and the reason
why i created this is because my dad's
family have spanier heritage so
realizing that this is a very popular
dish if i want to explore that other
half of my culture that i haven't been
really connecting with so when i made
this it's not only very simple but it's
very delicious even though a lot of
people here were not exposed to it felt
familiar with this dish but the
ingredients are so common that poo of
all kinds enjoyed it and asked me for
the recipe because that's how good it
was and i thought well this is the
perfect excuse to learn something new
and to explore and when i made it i
realized that it has a lot of
commonalities with the south american
culture not only that but this simple
dish has a lot of potential to connect
with people who are not even latin
american because the ingredients are so
common so really you don't have to go to
spain to get a little authentic taste of
this culture you can just grab a couple
of tomatoes eggs and then play with
these ingredients and you will be eating
authentic spainier cuisine
[Music]
one of my favorite recipes called
aborrajado because it's colombian which
is where i'm from also because it's
super easy and delicious so this is the
first video that i'm making which is
amazing it's great but i get this i'm
making this with adam bianchi which you
probably know from worth it so it comes
in part what we have to get diabol
rajado break it in half and get that
beautiful cheese pull and this dude
looks at me
the pressure takes over and there i am
breaking that thing as he's looking at
me like you can't do it
and it happened
it was incredible i managed to get a
smile out of bianchi you know he never
smiles what i did and i'm still in the
books on record as the one and only
person who made him smile
when we published it in the comments a
lot of people are started claiming this
recipe as theirs meaning ecuador and
people were saying that's actually
ecuadorian peruvians puerto ricans so it
was really cool to realize like okay
this is like what i thought was a
colombian recipe is actually this latin
american recipe that a lot of people are
calling different names and make it in
different ways so it's ours it was kind
of enlightening to realize that what i
thought was ours is really latin
american and it's so easy really all
you're doing is grabbing some sweet
plain tame frying it flattening it and
then you put whatever you want inside in
colombia we put a little bit of cheese
and sometimes a little bit of guava
paste it's so amazing to see these
different interpretations of such a
delicious and simple dish and guess what
not only did we get the cheese pull it
was one of the most successful videos
that we had on be a tasty so thank you
adam
alright you and i know that bread
pudding does not belong to colombia or
latin america but it's a very popular
dessert because what you're really doing
is grabbing any extra bread that you
have laying around home and adding
whatever you want in this case i noticed
that there was a little twist people
were adding a little bit of dulce de
leche which is like caramel and instead
of the just sugar and heavy cream we
were adding
condensed milk which has everything it's
creamy has the sugar it's milky so you
have everything in this one ingredient
when this was ready to go out people
tried it there was this girl at work her
name is merle she
never had it before not in this way at
least and she said can i just grab a
little bit can i grab a little bit more
it was so popular a lot of people were
texting me for recipes and begging me to
please make it all over again and so i
did if you want to please a big crowd
this is your option
so green plantain gives us a couple of
things which are tostones also known as
patacon in my country in colombia so
tostones is really just cream plantain
that has been fried and then it's
flattened and then it's fried again so
i'm going through instagram i realized
that there are a couple of places in
colombia who are making this plaintain
cone and it's super cool because now you
have amazing delicious plantain with a
feeling on the go inspired by all of
this post and this new trend i decided
to bring it to tasty and to my surprise
it was super successful a lot of people
from different cultures embraced this
idea and soon after articles from around
the world started talking about this
plantain count which again not my
creation but it was trending in my
country now the whole continent knew
about it it was cool to realize that by
publishing this video i was somehow
highlighting this little dish in a
little tiny corner of the country and at
the end of the day a lot of small
businesses benefited because the recipe
becomes popular and it's super cool
because now you have amazing delicious
plantain with a feeling on the go
inspired by all of this post and this
new trend
papa regena is very popular in places
like peru and colombia all it really is
is mashed potato which houses whatever
you want it can be beans ground beef and
that's really the whole concept so i
came to the united states when i was
about to turn 15. and one of the things
that i noticed immediately is that
although people do try to bring back the
dishes from different countries there
was something missing here now that i'm
working out being tasty i get to share
those dishes that i missed so much when
i arrived and i get to share them with a
lot of people in a lot of countries so
it's crazy how things played out for me
to be able to still work with my culture
as part of my job that's insane every
single dish it's an expression of some
kind maybe it's a really fancy chef who
wants to
show off his amazing culinary skills or
it's just a grandma in ecuador
who is really eager to share her
longtime tradition of apar regenas
whatever it is it's a message in every
dish at the end of the day you're eating
a little bit of someone's story maybe
it's just the story of how this dish
arrived to existence maybe it's the
story of the influence of other cultures
to yours whatever it is as a fan of
stories of storytelling
i try to appreciate as much as i can any
new dish not just for its flavors and
its looks but for its origins and that's
something that i'm lucky enough to do in
every single video that i'm putting out
there for being tasty and i get to do it
with a massive audience alright so if
you have not gotten a chance to explore
non-mainstream latin american recipes
then please i beg you to try this ones
because they're delicious they're easy
to make they're affordable and most
importantly you will be eating authentic
amazing latin american dishes try them
oh yes
[Music]
you